foreign
okay Sarah where did you get all these
numbers and it just goes silent she goes
out of my butt
dumbest thing I've ever done with money
is I let a friend talk me into a
multi-level marketing purifying water
thing that I never sold and honestly it
was so stupid you want me mowers I got
four I got four mowers the dumbest thing
I've ever done with money I kept paying
for a gym membership for three years
because I told myself I'd go soon and I
never did
um I've got three deep freezer those one
I've got a problem okay I got a problem
the dumbest thing I ever did with money
was to go deeply in debt buying a bunch
of real estate in my 20s which caused me
to go bankrupt because I was dumb I once
shipped a pair of shoes on Craigslist to
Nigeria for a guy's cousin and it was a
scam
honestly probably when I buy like
expensive designer stuff then my wife's
like wow we have two deep freezers why
do we have a third I'm like here's what
I think I think what's about to happen
is zombies
there's a lot of calls that are on a
spectrum from hilarious to heartbreaking
to strange
um and Dave you've had the brunt of this
having taken over uh almost a hundred
thousand calls based on some rough
napkin math we did wow I know it's hard
to pinpoint some of the weirdest or
funniest moments but are there any that
are burned into your memory that have
become a core memory for you I I can't
help myself I got a greatest hit request
okay he's walking us right to it you got
to tell about the call the guy who had
the brilliant idea for the telephone
booth oh God because I feel like this is
a perfect it represents the stranger
I've completely melted down on the air
and laughter to the point I couldn't
recover two times in 30 years
I could not get it back you know where
you just get that laugh and you're just
like it won't stop like 13 year old
girls it's the church giggle you can't
Church giggle yeah you can't stop you
can't breathe you can't and the more you
try to try to get back you can't get
back and so yeah this guy calls in the
second second segment of the show and um
and this is a long time ago because
there were pay phones for those of you
don't know there were these phones we
used to put quarters dimes into and then
later quarters and you could make a
phone call that way and this guy calls
up and says um you know I figured out
how I can get free phone service in my
house and I said okay how are you gonna
do that and he says he says I'm gonna
put a pay phone in the house and I'm
like uh well somebody's got to have the
quarters to put in he goes well I'll
furnish the first set of quarters
because when they put the quarters in
then I'll take them out and give them
back to them and they can put them in
again and so I'll get free phones it
sounds like Congress and I'm like uh
dude you have to pay for the connection
he goes huh and I said when you put a
payphone in your house if it's not
connected with a fault line and I just
started losing it because because you
just bought a phone line that you were
trying to not buy and it's just and uh
this guy's this guy's dumber than a rock
and I just decided he beat the system
and I just started I just completely
melted down and I mean and you can hear
it in the audio it's just and finally uh
Blake just uh you know he was a producer
he just took it to commercial because I
couldn't get it back we went to
commercial early screwed up the whole
network the Affiliates were going
bonkers they didn't know what to do but
he just started playing commercials
because there was I was not coming back
I was thinking of the advisability of
putting in a pay phone instead of my
regular phone service because for eight
hundred dollars you can get a pay phone
Joe that you have to pay for the phone
line still yeah if you pick if you don't
hook the phone behind to the phone
you're not gonna have a daughter
okay well that's what I wanted to find
out if there was a hole in this it's
Gap
that happened to me once on the air that
I couldn't recover and I had to like
look down and I was just silent the rest
if I looked up I would have just started
what was it it was on the air with you
and this girl called and she was like
yeah and I can't I cannot remember who
she was or the numbers or anything or
even the story I don't even remember but
it was basically like
you know I have 30 000 in debt and I'm I
can do this thing where I sell this
thing and I'm gonna make 120 000 but I
just need to invest
a hundred dollars into this idea and I'm
gonna make all this money and and you
know and I'm and we're all like okay
okay so it doesn't Dave's asking her if
you you know clarifying questions and
finally videos okay Sarah where did you
get all these numbers
and it just goes silent she goes out of
my butt
out of my
life with the people in the booze when
the producers they're all laughing oh
yeah
and I was like and I just couldn't it's
hard for 10 seconds but then if you get
the laughs and you can't recover then
you're laughing at the fact I'm laughing
and then and then yeah and I was done
well and the booth guys got to where
they would just drop below this yeah the
floor and laugh because they knew if I
was looking at them laughing it was
going to make me start to lose it and I
couldn't my goodness but I've been able
to get through all of them how much are
you gonna charge
uh I was thinking probably like
100 to 200 per room where'd you get that
number
um out of my butt
well uh probably I'll do some more
research
oh lord of Mercy I'm losing it oh
we used to do a stupid tax hour
and people would call in if you've done
something stupid with money you lost
some money we called it stupid tax and
still do and uh the stupid tax stories
were hilarious I mean a guy calls up and
he goes uh would you I said would you do
that was stupid he goes I bought a
monkey
you bought a monkey he goes yeah spotted
knows gwinin and I'm like that's a thing
a monkey's car this he goes yeah it's a
big monkey and he goes yeah and I said
okay so he said I thought it would be a
cool pet
it was kind of a cool pet and then I
started dating this girl and I got
engaged to her and the monkey was
jealous oh boy of my fiance and it would
hit her and it would poop and throw its
poop at her oh my God and he goes and so
I ended up he said I paid 2 500 for the
monkey and he goes I ended up having to
give the monkey away I said you gave
away the spotted nose gwenin and he's
like yeah anything it was gay it was
just mean it was just mean it's jealous
and mean and hateful and I had to give
it away nobody would buy it
I bought a monkey you didn't I did a
spotted nose gwenin it was a spotted
nose gwinin yes it's a type of monkey it
was a beautiful monkey sounds like a
girl I went out with in high school
every time I try to kiss or hug on my
wife that monkey would try to punch my
wife with its little Fist and bottom
line is my wife she just didn't care for
that too much
you also bring that segment back yeah we
ought to do that that's gonna be a great
where are they now I'd like to know
where the monkeys
and the worst one was the guy that
called on the stupid text hour this was
the worst of all he goes yeah I spent
seven thousand dollars on my wife to get
breast implants oh my God and he goes I
come home
a week after she's home from the
hospital and I found her in bed with my
boss
and I drug him out in the front yard and
beat him up and the cops came and
arrested me he said so
I I put the operation on a credit card
he goes so I got seven thousand dollars
in debt
I got to go to jail I got fired I'm
getting a divorce and I never even
touched those things
we just about lost
yeah this could happen on the air you
got to be ready it's live radio oh man
well for every funny call there's also
some emotional heartbreaking some
intense calls where you know you're in
the middle of a really messy situation
uh any stick out to you guys you're like
this one I still think about mine was
mine was the time I wasn't on the air I
there's there's that bathroom in the
dressing room behind the recording
studio and I just walked by to use the
restroom and I waved into the control
boots to say hi to everybody and Kelly
who was the call screener associate
producer at the time
she had like in the crisis world we call
them crazy eyes when somebody can look
across the room and know there's a
something bad that's going on and she
waved me in and that's when I walked
into a call y'all were a part of that
ended up going for quite a while but
there was a moment when I go on the
phone with that woman I thought I
thought I was gonna hear her I thought I
was gonna hear her get killed
um she was just in a real abusive
situation in that moment and it was it
was like I had a boyfriend that was
beating a snot out of her and she's
caught calling us and he walked in while
she's talking asking about selling her
house she said I need to move yeah can I
move to get away from him and I'm like
no you need to leave him right now like
and she said now I said now right this
second go get your baby get in the car
and drive away do you have family in the
area you've got to get away from this
and he walks in and grabs the baby and
starts holding the baby and threatening
her she goes ends up sitting in the car
because he puts the baby in the
floorboard he's gonna drive away she
Dives in the back seat of that car and
so she's sitting in there with him and
John's on the phone I'm trying to talk
this guy down while we got the police on
the way and the cops roll up on bubba
and
so Bubba which was very intuitive of you
though because I remember because I was
on the air with you on that one and she
called and she's kind of out of breath
even and she's like I just need to know
um can I sell my house can I and it was
this like urgent seeing her voice and I
think you were the one that were like
okay
why safe right now why are you wanting
to sell your house and she was like well
I just said I need a I'm not in a good
situation I'm just not in a good
situation and you were like where is he
is he near you right I mean and you
picked it up and I mean I kind of was a
little bit more oblivious you zoned
right in on it and man and it was it was
like literally going on on the air of
him there and she's like he's just
walked out I mean
yeah it was scary in all fairness Kelly
said before we picked up the call she
said there's something going on here you
need to figure it out
she kind of she didn't know what it was
she said something's up and so I was
digging based on her input there wasn't
pure intuition
so are you going to sit there
in the middle of this sewage or are you
going to fix it
I want to fix it that's why I wanted
somebody home and I just want to go no
no honey we don't need to call A realtor
we need to get the boyfriend out of the
house and that's going to involve the
police and or your father and your
brothers
he needs to leave at your house
and you're afraid
you understand that this is wrong right
yes sir okay this is this is you're
you're not the crazy one
I'm talking to the same one you know
what I'm always trying to say it feels
like that yeah I know
all right I'll tell you what we're gonna
do we're gonna put you on hold and Kelly
is going to make sure that law
enforcement gets over there okay no sir
no here please no baby doll I'm not
gonna be I'm I'm not listening I love
you and that baby
do what
okay
I'm sorry I'm sorry it's okay it's okay
honey
you're you're in here
[Music]
listen easy breathe you're in a horrible
situation and you have to make the moves
to get away from it
but you don't have a financial problem
you need a boyfriend ectomy
[Laughter]
and it's happening today darling
it's happening today
Dave there is a level of discernment and
intuition you have I remember listening
before I worked here uh This American
Life did a feature on you and they were
actually digging into how you can hear
things in the caller's voice and call
things out that the average listener
would have no idea
and you go is he hitting you and they're
talking about some random money question
and they're shocked because you're right
how does that happen well I mean it's an
intimate medium and the you know where
you just we don't have a visual we don't
have body language
uh all you've got is voice and the
Cadence
in the voice it's um
in a sense it's like someone who's lost
their sight
because all you're using is one of your
senses
you know you're hearing and so you're
dialed in and if you just stay focused
on what's going on you can hear it uh I
mean I've heard all of you pick up on
you can tell when somebody's lying
in that setting more than you can in
person I think
because they'll give you the verbal
they'll give you the body language cues
and that kind of thing but they're
verbals off
and you can in person they can lie to
you each year but in this you'll hear
them you know that you get you go okay
so what's going on there and is this
what's happening and
you waited too long to answer yeah
you're having to make up a lie
you waited too long to answer and in
that case on that piece of video or
audio
um
again I actually had data that I had I
dealt with on one of the shows I was
doing in New York with uh one of the
talk shows with the psychologist on the
thing and she worked in a domestic
violence shelter when she wasn't working
on the show as a psychologist as a
counselor and she said she showed me the
data she said there's a huge High
correlation between a man who is
extremely overbearing and over
controlling on the money with him
hitting her so like she can't go to the
grocery store without him going with her
um she can't buy a stick of gum without
him he controls everything one thousand
percent and if it's like the more
extreme that is the higher the
probability that that there's domestic
violence and so this lady's like my
boyfriend won't let me go to the grocery
store by myself
Ian wants to he wants to control all the
money and I'm like
so how long has he been hitting you it's
like for her she's like where'd that
come from well I had that piece of data
but you could also hear her voice
that she was you know the way she's the
stress you could feel it in her octave I
mean in her vocal cords coming out and
so we just you know you just go
and the poor little person doing the
interview that was in the studio for
that other show
went we came off there and she goes how
did you know that I'm like I'm magic
well aside from all the funny and
emotional there's been a Cornerstone of
the show for almost as long as we've
been on air which is the debt-free
scream and uh you know about once an
hour we celebrate someone who's paid off
any amount of debt who went all in
following the baby steps following our
plan are there any debt-free screens
that stand out to you guys it's one of
my favorite parts of the show because
you just have a smile plastered on your
face as you look across the glass and
see those people who traveled from all
over the country are called in to share
their story
you know I think about probably the
heaviest and most uh
painful but beautiful debt-free scream
it was years ago in our uh old building
and it was a sweet mom single mom and
she's up there telling her story and she
just laid out the story of how her
husband died and and it's to this day I
think it remains one of the most
powerful calls but it was one of those
where normally those debt-free screens
are are moments of great celebration and
and it was but as she walked through the
pain of what she went through and how
much it meant to her and how much her
husband had been in on the journey and
see those little kids with her so now
you got a single mom who it was
heart-wrenching the loss that she went
through and you look at those kids and
they lost their daddy and and then you
kind of like that's colliding with the
fact that she's there heartbroken but
also celebrating and grateful for her
husband and his role and it's those
crazy moments where it's so heavy you
know it's like it's like the funeral
that everybody's sad but everybody's
happy you know it's like hey we know
where they are and it's gonna be okay
but it was those kind of that was
probably the most heavy thing and I was
just hosting the video channel back then
and I was staying in the lobby watching
Dave do that one and there wasn't a dry
eye in the studio the control room the
lobby and you know those are those are
powerful powerful moments when you
realize what this is all all about
and in two years you paid off your house
yes sir that was the
or dream it was our Dream Dennis's and
mine to make this happen and and God is
really good all right kids you guys been
practicing the debt free stream too all
right all right well this is about the
best one I've had in a while I'll tell
you that thank you sir so uh all right
Cynthia count it down ready
three two one
[Applause]
wow
oh man oh man
thank you Lord for work that matters
the one that I remember
um so I thought there's been so many
great ones uh was
Dave I think it was you and I that was
doing it and
you always ask the question how'd you
get started on this and that um
husband was it was a veteran and
he said I just kind of got to the point
where I need to make sure my family was
taken care of because I was going to
take my life I decided I'm done and so I
need to make sure everybody's good and
as a part of
I've seen it I declared a deck for my
family it's the right thing to do before
I take my life and
one of the things that you you were so
instrumental putting in the baby steps
long ago is you can't do this by
yourself you got to sit down with
somebody and so as as he sat down with
his wife
ultimately it came out and then they
started the journey to get his health
taken care of and get his men all taken
care of they end up with a new job just
the breadth of change that happened in
this family but it started with a guy
sitting down his wife saying I'm not
doing okay and so we like I think you
and I we've talked offline Dave you
couldn't have dreamed up a better
program for somebody struggling with
significant depression because
I'm going to give you a tiny little goal
meet this thousand bucks just do
whatever you got to do to meet this and
then I'm going to meet another goal and
a little goal that's the path out of so
many mental health challenges relational
challenges and the money challenges and
you end up trying to get out debt and
you end up fixing your marriage and all
and saving a life you end up doing all
this other stuff that just changes
everything uh about your about about
your about everything changes everything
about everything
so what happened let you on fire man you
all went off like fireworks uh honestly
uh it's pretty wild story uh I was
actually debating on whether I should
commit suicide or not
um and I wanted my family to be secure
when I was gone and then uh just
listening to your show and hearing the
Bible verses every day I came home and
talked to Tori and decided we should
probably get into a church uh we found
River Valley up in the Twin Cities and
uh gave our life to Jesus Christ got
baptized October 31st which is kind of a
joke and a half because our favorite
holiday was Halloween for a long time
and uh just changed our life ever since
yep amazing wow so was the financial
pressure part of that or just other
mental issues um I'm a disabled veteran
so I deal with PTSD and some traumatic
brain injury from from some of that so
wow
wow what's your uh healing Journey been
like
um you know it's uh it's been a process
I I got into a big good group of uh guys
at church some Men's Leadership courses
um starting counseling with the VA
coming up on August 1st so very good
congrats man very good it's awesome
and another one that sticks out to me is
in the old building the Canad family
came to announce they paid off their
house and so we were celebrating them
and they had their kids with them and I
was hosting the video Channel all the
time they're grown kids they're grown
kids about my age and this is a middle
eastern family I grew up my parents are
Middle Eastern and so there was already
a connection there and they said hey
Dave before we do our debt free screen
we wanted our kids to be involved we
don't we didn't want to do this without
them so we wanted to surprise them today
and let them know that we've paid off
both of their houses oh my God and I
mean we were all just crying in happy
tears it was just such a shock and that
was one of the most special moments
because it made me go that's the kind of
Legacy I want to leave that's the kind
of dad I want to be
how old are the kids now they're not
kids yeah 29 and 30. okay and they're
well established in this
methodology and um in fact you know if I
could I just want to share something
they're also debt free with the
exception of their mortgage
um there is uh you know we don't have
any secrets they've been right there
with us but there's one thing that we've
kept from them and I'd like you kept
something from us yeah it was a little
secret and we thought let's just keep it
what kind of secret are you gonna do
right here on the radio the secret is
just because they're here and they're
gonna scream that free with us we would
like them to know that their mortgages
are paid off
okay
[Applause]
unbelievable
yes wow
[Applause]
they wow
you know we're really clear that the
best thing that we can leave to our kids
is the wisdom to know how to handle
their lives and and you guys are
changing your family tree big time
one of the interesting things being new
on the show is that having watched
debt-free screams for years and then
being on the show it's just they never
get old like you would think as a host
you might just be watching it being like
another person is on there but it's like
we stop on the brakes and go wow that's
so good like it feels I've caught myself
like tearing up on the brakes and being
like that is amazing and I think it's
cool here at Ramsey we have fans of your
fans and it's like we are such fans of
the people and everybody has such a
unique story that it still hits us every
time well with all of the the drama
that's created by the callers some of it
is created by us some of the controversy
George
I got to be a part of that the other day
Ken and it was really special Rachel and
I were on the air and we had a Katie
calling from Kentucky I remember all the
Katie from Kentucky Murray Kentucky okay
oh yeah this is this is my memory is
seared now yes he said one of those
stupidest things
it has a name now it's called horse gate
and so we've officially named it and
we're on the call with her and she's
going hey my side hustle is was
horseback riding my horse is injured I
need ideas for side hustles so we're
giving her some ideas hey there's a
local I'm Google and there's a local
Walmart in your area you can go make
some good money there you can dogs well
it's a real rural area she's it felt
like she was just on the justification
train
and they had left the station so we're
getting to the end of the call she makes
34 000 a year we find out she's a
hundred and twenty thousand dollars in
debt and so at the end that we're coming
up to the break and I go Katie I'm going
to challenge you could you sell the
horse
and she then go well I've had it for 11
years and and I went to Katie the horse
doesn't even know your name and Rachel's
looking to her she was just in horror
and shocks like the most intuitive
animal you could ever own well but I
think technically George is correct the
horse doesn't nowhere
she's like no this horse you know you
act like you call the horse a bed oh you
know all this George's like Oh Katie
doesn't even know your name go to pray I
was like oh my God here's the thing I
have a soul I've got two dogs everyone's
coming at me going would you sell your
dogs my dogs don't need a farm my dog
isn't worth twenty thousand dollars your
dog is not injured my dog's not in those
and but you're not 120 000 in debt I
know
I agree with you heard about our future
and I went she's never going to get out
of debt of this right if she doesn't
change her horse she's stuck because of
the horse I know and so we came back
from the break I tried to couch it all
it was not working and then you said you
said I wonder how much the horse would
go for you know and you're like I looked
it up you know what I can't remember 11
000. yeah and he was like you're she
said
and then he said Katie the horse is
worth more than you
kept digging the horse grave and I was
about to fall into it
now I gotta back off a horse is not
worth more than a person George I said I
said net worth Rachel not worthwise
because Katie you're negative 120.
there's been some regrets and how we say
things on air that then are plastered on
YouTube Forever you can't change and so
there are some regrets and she emailed
even that weekend with pictures of her
surprise winning horse so we even
wrapped it but I've mentioned I said
this to John yesterday I said I I care
about her future more than her feelings
but I could have cared about her
feelings too
in hindsight I know and horse people are
very passionate people and you went
after the horse Community passionate is
a very kind word yes
I've been trolled for days yes so
there's now a YouTube channel called
George Campbell's horse and I comment on
all of our videos just saying hey why
hey that's great it's great Katie I'm
going to give you a hard challenge could
you sell the horse
would you do it
I can't
why not
I've had this horse 11 years and Katie
Katie Katie there's other horses out
there it doesn't even know your name
there's more horses for you on the other
side listen I want Katie to win oh my
gosh she's got a mess to clean up I'm
doing whatever it takes I'll get another
horse later this is the Ramsay show
the student loan crisis is out of
control I mean 1.75 trillion dollars in
student loan debt it's just crazy that
at this point it is still such an issue
oh the government can just tell us we
all can't go to work right like I didn't
know that that was a thing I mean you
look at social media you look at
Tick-Tock I mean all these places that
now anyone can have a platform and a
voice and I think that's what's unique
about Ramsey is that we're the ones
usually tapping the brakes being like
let's just wait and see how this plays
out I have said if you follow the trends
you fall for the traps and that's what
we're seeing with these younger
Generations because there's super
targeted marketing that's going hey dude
all you need is ten dollars you're gonna
get ten thousand next week a promise or
how about Jason Bourne telling you a
fortune favors the brave